what we're going to do in this video is
look at two rectangles that have the
exact
same area and we're going to measure
each of them
with a different square unit so this fur
top unit right over here this is a
square foot so that means
its height is one foot
and its width right here is
one foot now this square
unit over here this is completely made
up
and i am going to call this a voot or
vout
so this right over here is
one foot and
this over here the width is one
foot so this entire thing is a
one square one square
foot while this top one of course
is one square foot
now let's measure each of the let's
measure the top rectangle
in terms of square feet and let's
measure the bottom rectangle in terms of
square
i guess i could say veet all right so
first the top rectangle
so we have one
two square feet three
square feet four square feet
five square feet and then
we have looks like six square
feet and then we're gonna need to have
another six square feet down here
so that's seven
eight 9 10
11 and 12.
so when i tile these square feet onto
our original rectangle looks like we
have 12
square feet and so i could write its
area like this
12 square
feet now what about this one in terms of
vt and one you could have a square foot
or many square
feet let me do the same exercise here
that's one square foot
this is two square feet
i could say and then this is
three square feet so the same
area could either be 12 square feet or
it could be 3 square
square feet and i want you to think
about whether that makes sense
think about how many square feet would
make up one square foot
in fact we can figure that out on our
own right over here
so that's one square foot this is
two square feet this is three square
feet
and then four square feet so it looks
like
four square feet make up one square foot
and so think about does it make sense
that three square feet
is the same thing as 12 square feet